this is what happens in France
look at this gentleman who says
I have my boss who can't recruit
he is obliged to take undocumented migrants
but declared to the bearsaf of course
so I don't know the protocol
compared to bearsaf and undocumented migrants
on the other hand
I know that France will make residence permits
for jobs in difficulty
where bosses can't find employees
so the courage
of the immigrants we will say of the undocumented will pay
well here it is so we can't
there are things happening in France
there are many who
spit on the backs of immigrants
but in the meantime
there are plenty of jobs
that are not taken by the French
then maybe
compared to the fact that it doesn't pay very well
okay but in the meantime
there are places
for people
who really want to come to work
in France
they will change the selection criteria
it will be necessary to
speak French before six months ago
when you arrived in France to be able to work
you had to wait six months
time to get used to the culture of the country
and those six months are catastrophic in fact
because the
people who really wanted to work
well,
after six months
they didn't want to work anymore in fact
so this is what happens so France
is solving all these problems
and so much the better